[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELISSA DANIELS: Hi, all.
Welcome to Women
Techmakers Panel--
Experiences Developing
On Android Things.
My name's Melissa.
I'm a Program Manager
here at Google.
And I work on the
Android Things team.
And so in a moment,
I'm going to let
the wonderful and
amazing women to my side
introduce themselves.
And we're going to
talk about how they're
all Googlers, and how
they all work together
on a series of projects actually
based on Android Things.
So over the next
40 minutes, we'll
actually walk you through their
prototype to production story.
What they learned, what they
loved, and of course, what they
loathed along the way.
So let's meet our lovely ladies.
Let's start with Rachel.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Sure.
Hi, I'm Rachel Petterson,
and I am a Software Engineer
at Google, obviously.
MELISSA DANIELS: I'm
going to interrupt you.
Let's do this true
Google fashion.
So why don't you tell us
how long you've been here?
And also, a fun fact, too.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Sure.
I can tell you what
I work on also.
So I have been at
Google for 10 years.
I work on Google Cloud Search,
which is our enterprise search
solution.
And a fun fact is that
before coming to Google,
I used to work on visual
effects for movies.
And I've got a credit
in "Transformers."
MELISSA DANIELS: Nice.
CARSON HOLGATE:
I'm Carson Holgate.
I'm the Tech Lead on one of
Google's internal communication
tools.
I've been at Google
for five years.
And a fun fact about myself
is that I wrote the software
for a bartending robot.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yeah.
Yeah, that's really cool.
I'm Vaas Krishnamurthy.
I'm an Embedded Software
Engineer at Nest.
I've been there five years.
And fun fact about me, I've
been part of this dance group
called Bay Area Flash Mob.
We have danced at hundreds
of places in San Francisco,
from Pier 39 to Union Square
to even the Mayor's Ballroom
in the City Hall, by just
mingling with the crowd
and then just breaking
out into a dance.
MELISSA DANIELS: Did
you intentionally
dance in the Mayor's
Ballroom, or did he
not know that you were
going to [INAUDIBLE]??
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
No, [INAUDIBLE]..
It was for a wedding
that was happening.
MELISSA DANIELS: Oh my gosh.
Nice.
BRITTANY WILBERT:
That's awesome.
And then, my name's
Brittany Wilbert.
I am a Privacy Engineer
here at Google.
And one fun fact about
myself is that I'm
a builder and a tinkerer.
And most recently, I
built three 3D printers.
MELISSA DANIELS: Awesome.
So thanks for introducing.
So you guys will all hear a
little bit about everything
that they've done
along the way and how
they use Android Things.
And so for those of you
who aren't familiar,
all these projects were
built for something
called Grace Hopper.
So Grace Hopper is the
world's largest gathering
of women technologists
every year.
And each year,
Googlers participate.
And this past year,
my team, Android
Things, partnered with
the Women Techmakers Team,
which is a global program
for women in technology.
And so Google's Women Techmaker
Team actually helps to work,
provide visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology to drive
innovation and participation
in the field.
So they do this through things
like hosting events, launching
resources, piloting new
initiatives in organizations.
And obviously, teaming up
with fun teams like mine.
I mean, I'm a little biased
because it is my team.
But to make sure that
women all over the world
are supported in their industry.
So naturally, when the
opportunity came up for us
to work with the
Women Techmakers Team,
and then find a whole
bunch of amazing volunteers
across Google to build things,
we jumped at the chance.
So how did you
guys get involved?
So I know, obviously, how I got
involved because I got excited
and was involved with the
Women Techmaker Group.
But how did you
guys get involved?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON:
Sure, I'll take that one.
So around sometime in July--
so Grace Hopper is October.
Around July, Melissa
sent out an email,
basically asking for volunteers
to work on something for Google
involving Android Things.
I personally had been involved
with Grace Hopper at Google
for many years.
And so this sounded
like something
different and interesting, so I
was really excited about that.
And plus, I had
really been wanting
to get involved in
internet of things
and this seemed like a great way
to blend those two interests.
CARSON HOLGATE: And I was trying
to get tickets to Grace Hopper,
but I couldn't.
MELISSA DANIELS: I
was your free pass?
CARSON HOLGATE: Yes,
you were the free pass.
Also, the free pass to I/O.
MELISSA DANIELS: Don't tell.
CARSON HOLGATE: So I wanted to
get involved with Grace Hopper,
and I saw this email come from
Melissa about Android Things.
And I have some Android
experience and some hobby
hardware experience, so I figure
I'd be able to contribute.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: And
I saw Melissa's email,
and I had heard about Android
Things, never used it.
So thought, this is
my chance to use it.
And also, this was my chance
to meet other great women
at Google, which I did.
And so I signed up.
BRITTANY WILBERT: And for
me, I was actually a Noodler,
a new Googler at the time.
So I wanted to find something
that would be interesting,
where I could meet new fellow
Googlers at the company
and just learn more.
So fortunately, this
came in my mailbox
and I was able to
take a part of it.
MELISSA DANIELS:
And none of you guys
really knew each other
before this, right?
You guys kind of
knew each other?
CARSON HOLGATE: We
knew other, yeah.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
Not as well as we
do now, though.
CARSON HOLGATE:
Yeah, that's true.
MELISSA DANIELS: Now,
you tolerate each other.
And from that, you
guys just instantly
knew what you wanted
to build, right?
So you saw that email from me
and you're like, Grace Hopper.
Android Things.
Got it.
Going to do this.
I know exactly what's
going to happen, right?
CARSON HOLGATE: Yep.
MELISSA DANIELS: Oh, OK.
I feel like you're lying to me.
Actually, can we go through
what that process was like?
How did you come up with-- or
ideate and go through things?
What did you build?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
So for Steve--
OK.
Well, I'll talk about
what we did build.
We built Steve the Tree,
which Steve is a giant
20-foot-by-20-foot footprint
and 17-foot-tall tree.
So it takes up a
lot of space there.
Steve is a Joshua Tree.
That's what he was based on.
And we built
everything in Steve.
So the tree itself.
It's got Rebar core, foam,
completely flame retardant.
Fire Marshal was
all good with that.
And then, he's covered
in about 5,000 LEDs
and 20-some-odd
sensors, including
force-resistive sensors,
microphones, light sensors,
gesture sensors, so that
attendees to the event
could interact with
Steve and wave to him.
And he reacts through his LEDs.
Through the frequency,
and the color,
and how many are showing.
But Carson, you want to talk
about what he started as?
CARSON HOLGATE: Sure.
We didn't start with the
idea of Steve the Tree.
Steve was originally
supposed to be a smaller
part of a larger open-world
interact with the things
kind of game.
And it all converged into Steve.
And we incorporated
a lot of the ideas
for the different
kind of sensors
and the light show
into the main tree.
MELISSA DANIELS: So you
keep calling him Steve.
Why?
Where did the name
Steve come from?
CARSON HOLGATE: So all of
my things are named Steve.
The bartending robot
is named Steve.
My Roomba is named Steve.
MELISSA DANIELS: Is
there a real Steve?
CARSON HOLGATE: There
is a real Steve.
Steve was a friend of
mine who works at Verily.
He's the nicest guy
you will ever meet.
MELISSA DANIELS: Is
he also a bartender
or a tree in his free
time, or anything?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
MELISSA DANIELS: Oh, OK.
Good to know.
So based off of this,
it sounds like you were
building with tons of sensors.
What does this look like?
So what were you
guys doing here?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Right.
So they were working with a
bunch of different sensors.
And prior to this, I hadn't
worked with Android Things.
And I hadn't really
done much with hardware.
Actually, the slide
that you're seeing here
is me connecting two
different-- actually,
four different
force-resistive sensors using
analog-to-digital converter.
There are easier ways to
do this that I now know,
but there was a lot of
learning that took place
in building Steve.
MELISSA DANIELS: And then,
these are all the lights
that you're talking about?
CARSON HOLGATE: This is the demo
that we did in the local Google
Makerspace.
Laid out all 16
strands of 5-meter LEDs
and wrote different values so
we could show the light show
and make sure it all worked.
MELISSA DANIELS: So
is Steve here at I/O?
Can we find him?
CARSON HOLGATE: Steve would
have loved to make it.
And we would love
to have him here,
but he put down
roots in Houston.
MELISSA DANIELS: And
this is basically--
you mentioned he was built
with Rebar and all this stuff.
So this is basically
the construction.
He's pretty big.
I mean, that's pretty
impressive and massive, right?
I mean, I've never
built a 20-foot tree.
I don't know about you guys.
So what about you two?
So tell us what you guys built.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yeah.
We built Rosie the Android.
She is a walking
and talking android.
So she is controllable
using a phone app
using a nearby connection.
And on the top, she has a camera
that can capture a picture.
And it can do some
image processing.
And it can detect
facial expressions.
And it can detect accessories
and speak to the audience.
She can also tell
them, hey, nice hat.
I like your smile.
Nice to meet you.
So she would raise her right
arm and offer a handshake.
MELISSA DANIELS:
So how big was she?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
She was huge.
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yeah.
So the first version of
Rosie was about 4 feet tall,
including the rubberized
wheels that were at the bottom.
She was actually made out of--
the first version, out of styler
foam, wood pallets, and a trash
can.
So we initially wanted
to use other methods,
but this was the
solution that we can make
in such a short amount of time.
MELISSA DANIELS: And so I heard
there's a rumor that Rosie
is here on-site today.
Is that correct?
Is this the same version
that you guys built,
or is this a different version?
Or what did that
process look like,
from going from a
base like this--
I believe that's a
trash can lid, right?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
Yeah, that's just
the lid of a trash can, yes.
MELISSA DANIELS: So how did you
go from a trash can lid to--
I believe there's a
giant robot outside?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Oh, yeah.
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yeah.
It was a lot of work.
So the initial
version of Rosie was
going to be something similar.
Maybe not as similar as what was
happening today, but we went--
going to hardware design.
But today, it has evolved to
a 5-foot-tall android that
can roam around that uses
machine learning techniques,
as well as the implementation
that Vaas worked on as well.
So it's really awesome.
MELISSA DANIELS: So it's
really like the prototype--
you guys truly went
through and prototyped her
and had your initial
contact version of Rosie.
And then, took your
iteration of her,
and then ended up with
sort of a production
version that we see out in
the world right now, right?
And all built in Android Things?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yes.
MELISSA DANIELS:
It's pretty cool.
I mean, I've
interacted with her.
She's pretty awesome.
OK.
It looks like you guys--
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
Yeah, that's us
at a hardware store
buying the trash can.
And yeah.
MELISSA DANIELS: So was that
always the plan, to build her--
you mentioned that
you had to shift
the plans and stuff like that.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yes.
MELISSA DANIELS: What
was your initial plans?
If it wasn't to use a
trash can and to use foam,
how did your design and
your evolution change?
BRITTANY WILBERT: So the
first version of Rosie
was actually created
using a CAD file.
So it took about two weeks
to create the CAD file,
and then we went around to
different shops to ask them,
hey, can you build--
can you fabricate a 5-foot-tall
android in about a week or so?
And unfortunately, they said no.
And one of our fabrication
labs that is here at Google,
they said that it was way too
big for the specifications
that we provided.
So basically, with a
week and a half left,
we decided we still
want to do this.
So we went to the
hardware store.
And we went to fabric stores and
got a cake box and other sort
of supplies.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Brittany
was really creative.
She got a styrofoam cake
box cover for the head.
We used PVC pipes for the arms.
And we used this giant
trash can for the body.
Yeah, it was quite
a lot of work.
MELISSA DANIELS: Definitely
an iterative process, right?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yes.
BRITTANY WILBERT:
Yes, definitely.
MELISSA DANIELS: It's amazing.
So we know how
Steve got his name.
So why Rosie?
Where'd that come from?
BRITTANY WILBERT: It's from
Rosie the Riveter, the World
War II-era individual who
inspired a lot of women
to decide to go out
into the working place.
So we wanted to have something
that a lot of visitors of Grace
Hopper would be interesting
in understanding
and have a good
experience with it.
MELISSA DANIELS:
It's pretty cool.
And I understand that's part of
like, what's built in to her ML
tech right now, right?
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yes.
MELISSA DANIELS: So you can
flex just like her head.
That's my poor flexing.
I don't know how
to flex apparently.
Just like Rosie.
And then, it will
trigger her ML?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yes.
MELISSA DANIELS:
That's pretty cool.
So getting back to all the
tech, you guys have all kind of
touched a little bit of this.
But all these MOs are
built using Android Things.
So before you started
working on Android Things,
did you guys have any
hardware experience?
Rachel, you said
no or a little bit?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON:
Most had been some LEDs,
but not really with
microcontrollers.
MELISSA DANIELS: Brittany,
you built a 3D printer?
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yes.
Vaas and Carson?
CARSON HOLGATE: I have half an
electrical engineering degree,
and I've done some hobby
hardware in the past.
But nothing--
MELISSA DANIELS:
Just half a degree?
CARSON HOLGATE:
Half a degree, yeah.
But nothing of the
scale of Steve the Tree.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yeah.
I've had hardware experience,
but I've never built anything
from scratch or to the scale.
MELISSA DANIELS: And
you guys had never
used Android Things before?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
No, not at all.
CARSON HOLGATE: No.
MELISSA DANIELS:
Well, not bad, right?
So because you hadn't used
Android Things before,
how did you actually
validate your software
through the development cycle?
So deciding to make Rosie's
arm move or Steve's lights
and all the sensors and stuff?
So what did that process
kind of look like?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
So in the case of Steve's,
each of the sensors
connects to an
Android Things card.
And the LED strips
also connect to cards.
But what we did was we
had each of the cards
would write to a
Firebase database.
And they would write
the raw values there.
And part of the
reason we did that was
because we didn't know
exactly what the situation was
going to be when we got to
the Women Techmakers event.
So for example,
the four sensors,
we knew that those
were going to have
grass over the top of them.
And we didn't know how much that
would affect the resistance.
And for the sound,
we had no idea
how loud people-- if people
were going to be shouting at him
or if there was going
to be background music.
So we accounted for that
by having everything
write to the database,
so we could then modulate
those values once we got there.
CARSON HOLGATE: Yeah.
So the sensors would write
to the Firebase database,
and then we had
Cloud functions that
would translate those raw
values into an aggregate
that the tree--
the individual strands
of LEDs would read from
and used to determine like,
how fast they're going
and what color spectrum
to run through.
That way, during the
event, if it got louder
or like something happened with
the four sensors on the floor,
we could change the code
on the fly on the server
and not have to go around to
every board and reflash them.
MELISSA DANIELS: Great.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
And for Rosie, I
started just by
downloading Android Studio,
trying out a sample app.
And then, I started looking
on GitHub for samples
that I could potentially
use on Rosie.
And I found this perfect
one for the movement
of the robot, which was--
it's called the Robot Car.
It's on GitHub.
If you look for
it, you'll find it.
So basically, it
gives you instructions
on how to compile,
how to load the app,
and build a small race car kit.
So I started with just building
this Range Rover race car kit.
And while debugging it,
Android Studio was great.
Because once you
plug in your phone
and your IMX 70, the
development board, you can see--
in two parallel tabs,
you can see the logs.
So you can debug the
connection that way.
So once I got the small
robot car working,
it scaled up to much bigger
wheels and much bigger,
higher-torque motors
that we needed to carry
the weight of the robot.
And similarly for the portion
with the image recognition,
we did the same thing.
I looked for things that
I could use with a kit.
The kit comes with an LCD
screen and a camera module.
So I went to GitHub and
looked for a sample that
would let me use all of this.
And again, I found this
Smile Detector sample
that was out there.
And that was great.
And I had replicated
the same thing
and pulled it in and
changed a bunch of things
to get it working on Rosie.
And for the arm
movement as well,
there is a simple PWM sample
that's in Android Things.
And yeah, put all these
different pieces together.
There were, obviously, a lot
of challenges for all of them
to work together.
For example, now
when I scaled up
to these bigger motors,
higher torque motors,
now they needed a much
more bigger battery.
That was operating on
a different voltage.
It was operating on a
much higher current.
So I had to buy a huge
light bulb battery.
But then, this board was still
powered off a 5-volt supply.
So a lot of learning there.
Definitely, a bunch of
burned motors in the course.
MELISSA DANIELS:
Just a couple, right?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yeah.
So in the end, everything
kind of came together.
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yep.
And Vaas did all the hard part.
I just did--
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
No, I don't think so.
MELISSA DANIELS:
I have a feeling
that's not even close to true.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: No way.
MELISSA DANIELS: Very
shared distribution.
So when you guys all
started at Google,
did you ever think
that part of your job
would actually entail
building, like giant robots
and giant trees?
Is that part of the Google--
CARSON HOLGATE: Yeah, that's
like standard Google software
engineer.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: No.
MELISSA DANIELS:
I don't remember
seeing that [INAUDIBLE].
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Not at all.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah, I
missed that part of orientation.
CARSON HOLGATE: You must
have been [INAUDIBLE]..
MELISSA DANIELS: Yeah.
So does any of this actually
translate over into the work
that you do every day?
I hope it does.
BRITTANY WILBERT:
Not so much anymore.
Well, like I said, I'm
a Privacy Engineer,
so I work in
security and privacy.
So most of my time
is set in the screen.
So having the opportunity
to be able to do something
on the side that is,
I guess forward-facing
is really awesome.
MELISSA DANIELS: Nice.
So if someone's
actually just getting
started with Android Things.
And they've poked
around a little bit,
and they have maybe a Raspberry
Pi or a microcontroller,
or they just have an idea.
Dream and a prayer, right?
Isn't that the phrase?
How do they get started?
What would you
recommend for how they
can build their own robots?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: I would
jump on the Android
Things website
and take a look
at the code labs.
So there are some code labs
on there that are really good.
They walk you through setting
up the whole Android Things.
So if you get a
kit-- and I think
there's a way to get a
kit while you're here.
MELISSA DANIELS: Yeah, I think
there's a scavenger hunt.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON:
There's a scavenger hunt.
MELISSA DANIELS: And also,
a giveaway, just FYI.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON:
So if you have a kit,
the code labs will walk you
through the entire setup
process.
And by the end of
them, I know there's
one that uses TensorFlow to
take pictures and identify dogs.
And that one's really cool.
But the important thing
is that by the end of it,
you've gone through
the experience.
And basically,
done the hard part
of learning how to get stuff
on Android Things and make it
do things.
And so once you jump
over that hurdle,
actually making changes and
doing stuff and adjusting it
for what you want
gets really easy.
CARSON HOLGATE: Yeah.
And I would say you
don't even really need
Raspberry Pi or
microcontroller experience.
If you know a little Android,
if you know a little Java,
it's easy to get up and started.
And the kits come
with a rainbow hat,
which has enough sensors to
build something cool right out
of the box.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yeah.
And you don't need hardware
or embedded experience either.
All the drivers for Android is
hidden behind these clean APIs.
So if you want to just
control the motor,
all you say is you set the
direction and the speed.
And that's it.
So you're not rewriting all the
device drivers from scratch.
You get the various
components working.
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yeah.
And I guess the biggest
thing, or least for me,
is to not be afraid.
I think a lot of people,
when they look at programming
opportunities, there can
be a concern that, hey, I
don't know what I'm doing.
But the Android Things
community is a great resource.
And then also, just
learning about it
and taking part and
getting hands-on
is a great way to get started.
MELISSA DANIELS: So it
sounds like between the group
of you guys, you're all
super-equipped, amazingly
talented.
Which no sarcasm, a
completely honest statement.
But everything went perfectly.
And so that you didn't need any
help building your giant trees
or your giant robots.
And you didn't run into
any problems at all, right?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yep.
BRITTANY WILBERT: No.
MELISSA DANIELS: Not even close?
Or should we talk about
the stuff that went wrong?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Yeah.
MELISSA DANIELS:
Start with Rosie?
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yes.
Like I said before,
we were planning
on building Rosie version 1 from
3D printers using fabrication
techniques to do so.
Unfortunately, it
was really big.
I didn't realize
that having something
like a 2-foot diameter waist
and all these other components
could cause such a concern.
So about two weeks before, after
exhausting every single option
made available to
us, we just said,
hey, we're just going to just
be scrappy and get stuff done.
So that's where the going
around a million hardware stores
came in.
MELISSA DANIELS:
So you're basically
saying your project was
too big for Google, right?
BRITTANY WILBERT:
Maybe at the time, yes.
MELISSA DANIELS: At least
for Google's 3D printer
at the time, right?
I feel like that's
an accomplishment.
That's pretty impressive, right?
So like, [INAUDIBLE]
moonshot the printers.
Isn't that the goal
[INAUDIBLE] So it's not bad.
So then, it sounds
like you guys,
when you went through
it, to move forward you
immediately-- your
next steps were
to think about the same
structure and redesign.
And then, think about how the
materiality came into play
with the software.
Is that correct?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
That's right.
So we started out
with something.
For example, we got
PVC pipes for the arms.
But later, when we
put the motor on it,
we found that that
was getting stuck.
And the PVC pipes
were just too heavy.
So we had to come up with
another solution, which
is when Brittany found
these perfect foam
arms that we could use instead.
And there are a lot
of other things, too.
For example, when we
put Rosie together,
even on these bigger
wheels, the weight
was too much for the
wheels to handle.
Because these wheels were
designed for a fast race car.
And so they couldn't take
the weight of the trash can.
So we had to cut
pieces of plastic
out so it can carry the weight.
And a lot of things.
Even with the camera, we
had to have enough lighting
to get the exact expression.
And we had to put it
at the right angle.
So every single step,
we had learned a lot.
We iterated and came up with
some solution for everything.
MELISSA DANIELS: Sounds like
a lot of time to get to it.
So obviously, I'm guessing
you had a ton of time
to build this, right?
How long did it take for
you guys to build Rosie?
BRITTANY WILBERT: So we
had a month initially.
But once the 3D
printing option failed,
it was about a week and a half.
And I guess more accurately,
more like three days
of late nights and a
few weekends trying
to figure out what we were
going to do when solving it.
MELISSA DANIELS:
That's not much time.
And how about for Steve?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON:
Steve, I think we put--
from the sensor side, I
think we put most of that
together in about
two to three weeks.
I mean, ideally we would
have had more time.
We would have
started immediately
when you sent out the email.
But there was a
lot of figuring out
what we were actually going
to do with Steve until Steve
became Steve.
CARSON HOLGATE: Yeah.
MELISSA DANIELS: And
you guys needed--
you felt like that was a
sufficient amount of time,
or you both needed
a lot more time?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: I
think we would have needed
two months at least full-time.
MELISSA DANIELS: But
you had three days?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Well,
we had like two weeks
to try and scramble.
But the last three
days were just insane.
The truck was waiting for us.
Rosie was still in parts.
We were still working on it.
And then, like packing
things that were done.
The head.
I had to carry the head
with me in the flight
because the rest of it
was already shipped.
So I carried the head of the
robot with me on the flight.
BRITTANY WILBERT: TSA
must have been very fun.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: What's that?
MELISSA DANIELS: That's crazy.
And so when you're building
Steve the Tree, a 20-foot tree,
nothing went wrong there, right?
So everything was perfect.
CARSON HOLGATE:
Everything was perfect.
MELISSA DANIELS:
That's good to know.
So just moving on.
CARSON HOLGATE: Not quite.
So I designed the main tree.
And while I was
designing the main tree,
I made a lot of assumptions
about how the hardware
and the software would work.
And of course, most
of them were wrong.
Initially, I thought
we were going
to be able to control
four strands of LEDs
from each board.
And then I got some
of the stands of LEDs
and I got some of the
boards and I realized
that this is not going to work.
The way that the LED strands
had implemented the standard
meant that I couldn't
do the things
that I thought I could do.
So the problem was
that the boards only
have one MISO pin to do the
data writing to the strand.
So I looked at using a technique
called bit banging, where
I picked apart the
headers in the standard
and I wrote just the individual
bits out through a GPIO pin
to light up the strand
and do the light show.
But I got about three
seconds per frame.
Whereas, doing it the right
way through the data pin,
I got 30 to 60
frames per second.
So I reached out to the
Android Things community.
And I'm like, this is
what I'm trying to do.
This is what I'm
expecting to happen.
And this is what's
actually happening.
And I hear back
that there's a layer
of abstraction between the
GPIO pins and the software.
For security reasons, of course.
So it wasn't going to work
the way that I wanted it to.
And this is like a common thing
with operating system-based dev
boards.
MELISSA DANIELS: Called
bit banging, right?
CARSON HOLGATE: Bit
banging was the technique
that I used to write
to the GPIO pins.
Then conveniently, we were able
to get a bunch more boards.
And the base of Steve the Tree,
as you saw in previous photos,
has 16 dev boards kind of
sitting around the base.
Each board is controlling
one strand of LEDs.
So it worked out on the end.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
And then, another
thing that we ran into.
So I mentioned before that
we were writing everything
to the Firebase database
so that we could make sure
that we could modulate
when we got to Grace Hopper
to account for the
different environment.
Well, we didn't really
account for the fact
that we had 20 sensors
writing about every second
to the Firebase database.
And we had 16 strips of
LEDs reading from it.
So it was a lot of in and
out to the Firebase database.
CARSON HOLGATE: It
was fine for a while,
until the night before the
event, when the whole tree was
set up and the sensors
were ready to go
and we were just testing things.
And then, the DJ got
there to test her setup.
I think she was playing a Bruno
Mars song with a lot of bass.
And because the tree
had microphones on it,
it was reacting.
It was like dancing
along to the music.
Then suddenly, the whole
tree stops working.
So we scramble to figure
out what's going on.
Like, we check connections.
And eventually, I open
the Firebase database logs
and I see that we're
out of free quota.
And I'm just so happy.
MELISSA DANIELS: I
feel like you've all
run into this problem
at some point, correct?
CARSON HOLGATE: I'm
just so happy it
happened the night before the
event and not during the event.
So Melissa and I
start scrambling,
trying to figure out how
to fix our quota issues,
like going through
official channels.
And eventually,
reach out to someone
I'd worked with on the
Firebase team before.
Because my real project
works with Firebase.
And he was able to
fix the quota problems
and we were up
and running again.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
And so later that night--
the event took place at Epcot.
And Epcot does this whole
laser light, fireworks show.
And so later in the evening,
the fireworks are going off.
And Steve is going
with the fireworks.
And it was kind of
like a nice sign
that, OK, everything is
going to be all right.
CARSON HOLGATE: Going to work.
MELISSA DANIELS: But
does some of this
mean that you guys
didn't account for noise?
Does this also mean you
were just more successful
than you anticipated?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
It was more about the
scale of the project.
MELISSA DANIELS: Hard to design
for something at that size,
right?
I think that's a good takeaway.
That when you're
starting out, it's
really hard to think
about something
at giant magnitude and stuff.
And so you're able
to build and iterate.
So it sounds like between all
of you guys, your software
experience and background
with Firebase actually helped
with learning a little
bit about Android Things
that troubleshooting some of
the problems that you ran into.
Is that an accurate statement?
Do you think it made
it a little bit easier
to get going [INAUDIBLE]?
CARSON HOLGATE: Yeah.
And definitely having
Android experience
helps, especially with an
Android-based platform.
And the Firebase
stuff was great.
Because usually, when you're
working with dev hardware,
you have to figure
out how the boards are
going to communicate.
Is it going to be Bluetooth?
Is it going to be [INAUDIBLE],,
one of those things?
But because this is Android,
and all of the Android libraries
and ecosystems come
along with this,
we could just write to Firebase.
We didn't have to worry about
the inter-board communication.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Yeah.
If you know any
Android, it makes
it a lot more comfortable.
Because at least
in my case, I was
learning internet of things
mostly for the first time.
And so Android was a very
comfortable environment for me,
so I could focus on
the internet of things.
And I wasn't learning 16
different things at once,
just focusing on
the one I needed to.
MELISSA DANIELS: You guys?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: I had
no experience with Android,
so this was all new.
MELISSA DANIELS:
Everything from scratch.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
Everything was from scratch.
But having the hardware
experience helped definitely.
MELISSA DANIELS: Great.
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yeah.
And for me, like I said,
software engineering
isn't directly my
day-to-day job,
but looking up the
Android community,
and then having coworkers
who have experience
has been really great and
was a great experience.
MELISSA DANIELS: So
what was something
that you guys took
away from this?
Or is there anything
that you felt
like you've learned from this?
Hopefully, you
learned something.
Maybe?
Yeah.
Any big takeaways?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON: So I
learned that overnight shipping
is really awesome.
There were definitely
a lot of things
that I ran into
working on the sensors.
For example, realizing
that I needed
analog-to-digital converters the
night before we had to leave.
And doing some
late-night soldering.
So getting those
overnighted was awesome.
So yeah, that--
MELISSA DANIELS:
Lifesaver, right?
CARSON HOLGATE: I learned
just to ask for things.
When I started
designing the tree,
I looked for the open source
drivers that were available
and the kinds of LEDs
that we could use.
And I found these
5-meter strands of LEDs.
And I'm like, OK.
We're building a tree.
We want to be able to
get to the base of it,
so the branches
should probably start
about six feet off the ground.
So 5 meters minus 6
feet is about 10 feet.
So then suddenly, we have this
20-foot-by-20-foot footprint.
And I'm like, this is insane.
But I kept going, just so
I'd have the design doc
and be like, look at this
thing that we could have built
that would have been awesome.
And at the end, I
put in a couple notes
about how we could
make it smaller
or cut it in half
because I didn't
think it would fit within our
budget or in the event space.
And then I sent it off to
Melissa and she's like, oh, no.
This is fine.
We can do this.
MELISSA DANIELS: No big deal.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
So for me, when
I signed up for this project,
I had no idea what was coming.
I didn't even know we were
going to build a robot.
We had a lot of ideas we were
throwing around, figuring out--
and hey, robot sounded cool.
So we signed up.
But everything seemed
doable to a certain extent
until the 3D printing
fell through.
And at that point,
we weren't sure
whether we should
give up or keep going.
And then, just build it
from scratch ourselves.
So that was really,
really scary.
But we didn't give up.
We just kept going and going.
Pushed it.
And finally, we said, OK,
let's get one portion working,
and then let's move
onto the other one.
But in the end,
everything came together.
All the electrical
circuits worked perfectly.
And she looked beautiful,
like a pretty Android.
And everything was great.
So my takeaway is that--
have the confidence in yourself.
Believe in yourself.
And keep trying.
It will pay off.
BRITTANY WILBERT:
And for me, I know
this is cliche, but don't
be afraid of failure.
Vaas was mentioning, we
had a lot of iterations.
We were first going to use a--
rather well-known licensed
character from a large company,
but then we evolved
from that to Android.
And then, the 3D
printing failing.
And just a lot of
things in between that
didn't come out as the way
that we initially thought.
But ultimately, we used
those failures as a way
to learn and understand what
was going on and improve.
And we were able to get an
awesome result after that.
MELISSA DANIELS: I don't
think they're failures.
I think they're just like
growing pains, right?
BRITTANY WILBERT: Maybe like
constant iteration periods
to a successful model.
MELISSA DANIELS:
So then, from that
I can't let you guys
go without asking,
what's the next
thing you're planning
to build using Android Things?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: So when
I'm not a software
engineer or normally
building Android Things,
I do a lot of dancing.
And so I'm really,
especially now
that I know that the microphones
worked really well with sound,
I'm hoping to incorporate
some Android Things
props into some of the dance
performances that I do.
CARSON HOLGATE: And
I'm looking at how
to add Android Things
to my bartending robot.
So that when someone
walks up with a glass,
it'll trigger the assistant
integration and be like, hello.
What are you drinking today?
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: And I'm
planning to build a Halloween
project for my kids.
And the kids in the block.
It's probably be
a candy dispenser,
which has a bunch of pressure
sensors and proximity sensors.
So when kids walk up to it,
it'll dispense candy for them.
BRITTANY WILBERT: Yeah.
And for me, I have
recently learned
how to use a sewing machine.
I always knew how to hand
knit, but I was always
scared of the machine.
So my goal is to hopefully
integrate Android Things
into some of the textile
work that I'm working on.
MELISSA DANIELS: Great.
And then with that,
is there anything
else you think that people
should know before we
bid this all adieu and move on?
No?
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Well, definitely
do the scavenger hunt.
CARSON HOLGATE: Yeah.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: So you
can get yourself an
Android Things kit.
MELISSA DANIELS: Cool.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN PETTERSON: And
then, hop on those code labs.
MELISSA DANIELS: Yeah.
All right.
Thank you so much.
And also, thank you
so much for building
the amazing projects you guys
did in working with our team.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: Oh, yeah.
We do have-- so just
to mention real quick--
MELISSA DANIELS: There's more.
RACHEL WEINSTEIN
PETTERSON: We do have--
we've got hackster IO pages
for both Steve and Rosie.
So if you want more
details, if you
want to be able to see
some of these pictures
up close and personal.
And really, hopefully
compliment our work.
Not analyze it too much, you
definitely take a look at those
and check him out.
Also, if you have
questions about it,
it's a great way to
post those questions.
And hopefully, we can
answer them for you.
MELISSA DANIELS: Great.
Sounds good.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: I
want to thank Melissa.
Without Melissa's efforts
and initiators, none of us
would even know each other.
Thank you.
She's always there for us.
She's always there
to support us.
And we really, really
appreciate everything
that you've done for us.
MELISSA DANIELS: I
just gave you stuff.
BRITTANY WILBERT: No, you
did all the hard work,
like providing water
and food while we
were about to go crazy.
Crazy's not the right word.
As we were trying
to get work done.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
Thank you, Melissa.
MELISSA DANIELS: Happy to help.
And I'm so happy this
was able to happen.
So thank you, guys,
all for attending.
So happy you're here.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]